oh it is crazy it's more stressful than
we thought it's a little surreal it's
like very once you start seeing the
prices yeah you go wedding shopping and
venue shopping and you're like oh my god
this is real and this is something we're
gonna have to pay for it it's a little
nerve-wracking but super exciting so
we're trying to get marry for next
summer so it's not fast paced but you
know but you know you have to book your
venue like a year ahead of time they
were saying that women booked their
venue two years at a time before they
even met they're engaged and we didn't
do that but we've like yes officially
unpacked of suitcases
how excited you guys you know for your
big moment here again for everybody to
see we're a little nervous nervous I'm
super excited but definitely nervous I
just hope I don't sound like an idiot
does it he sounds great I was very
long-winded I definitely took my time so
we wish we could do it on TV but like
you know they just we're doing it on our
own right now watching to see which
person is surprised you own this season
of The Bachelor Leo really leo
we didn't think what's gonna be so
thrown yeah Leo's kind of disappointing
but we will see where that goes I'm not
surprised by Jordan because I kind of I
like Jordan the Bachelorette I knew I
was gonna like him in paradise
Tia I think T is the biggest prize oh my
god I am loving to you so much I liked
her on RA season but I'm like oh loving
her now and the whole Colton India
storyline it's kinda close to our heart
so we're rooting for them you know this
is really funny she's certified
you
[Music]